- الكثير من الناس تعني كعكة الجزر
حلوى لذيذة مصنوعة من الجزر جيدًا ،
ولكن في سنغافورة كانت طريقة
Visio Patel المنزل العالمي
هي كعكة الجزر التي تعتمد على
طبق تقليدي كعك الأرز المقلي الذي
تم إحضاره إلى سنغافورة من قبل المهاجرين
هذا النمط من  كعكة الجزر هي طبق لذيذ
مصنوع من دقيق الأرز والفجل الأبيض
والذي يُعرف أيضًا باسم الجزر الأبيض
ومن هنا جاء اسم كعكة الجزر في
سنغافورة حيث تمت إضافة الفجل
مما جعله الطبق معروفًا ومحبوبًا من قبل
السنغافوريين السنغافوريين مثل هذا الرجل
جيدًا.  لم يتم إعطاؤك أنا أنت يانك
دائمًا ، كيف يمكنني قراءة الكثير من
الأغاني ، حسنًا ، لقد أخبرتها عادةً ما
تتبع قليلاً ، لذا أعطت الزميل الذي
عملت معه بالفعل اليوم ، إنه شائع جدًا
بحيث يمكن العثور على حجر في
كل شيء تقريبًا  مركز الباعة المتجولون حول
المدينة عبارة عن pussy de Matos oli ، أعني
مرات أصل الكلمة يوتا ، لذا هنا تضيء لا
أراهم الآن أو الأطفال بعض الجرعات ،
لذلك ما أفكر به يا سام حتى نعم
ياهو يجذبني لدرجة الجنون لدرجة أن بوو  k
ومع ذلك فإن mohkumat II له أخطاء مطبعية أو نحن في
رسوم كيميائية قابلة للأكل باللون الأصفر نقول أوه إنه
بالفعل تعلم هل تعلم
أن إخباره الذي يفصله عن
البائعين الآخرين هو أنه واحد من آخر
الأشخاص المتبقين الذين جعلوا ذلك باليد
يمكن للحب  أذيت سو كامبل ، حسنًا ، لذلك نحن نصنع
الكباب المفقود ، حسنًا ،
أيا كان البعد الذي يجب أن نضعه في الكلية في
مكان ما حول ما نقوم بإزالته ،
فهناك جيدًا كيف يمكن أن يكون هؤلاء قادرون في أي
دقيقة على أمل أن يحصلوا على كل شيء
بوق صغير في سنغافورة سأضعه
حسنًا ،
قطع الوسيلة كيف يكون ذلك جيدًا حتى لا يكون هناك فتيان في جميع
أنحاء جبن الموزاريلا
أنت
[موسيقى]